Abschreckung statt Aufnahme ändert
Deutschland die Asylpolitik das ist
unser Titel und Thema heute um
22:14 an diesem Donnerstagabend einen
guten Abend liebe Zuschauer die Zahl der
Flüchtlinge ist im Moment zu hoch sagt
der Bundeskanzler das wegt die Erwartung
dass er daran bald etwas ändert an der
CDU soll es nicht scheitern aber worin
kann sie bestehen diese nächste
Zeitenwende dann beim Asyl mehr
Abschreckung und Abschottung besonders
schwierig ist das für die Grünen in
Europa hat man sich gestern geeinigt auf
eine asyreform aber ob und wann die
etwas bringt ist ungewiss wir müssen
reden mit diesen
Gästen der Parteichef der Grünen omit
nuripur Thorsten frei von der CDU
Ulf Kämpfer Oberbürgermeister von
Kiel Anja Meer vom
Fokus der
Migrationsforscher
und der Architekt des türkeiabkommens
Gerald
Knaus sie sind zu Gast bei Maybritt ner
alle Gäste sind ausgesprochen herzlich
begrüßt ist das alles nur Wahlkampf was
wir erleben hier im Land liebe Zuschauer
oder steht Deutschland vor einer Wende
in der
Asylpolitik die Zahl der Flüchtlinge in
Deutschland ist zu hoch sagt der Kanzler
itz wer hat es ihm verraten der
Oppositionsführer die Umfragen ein
klares Wort vorweg die Zahl der
Flüchtlinge die nach Deutschland Streben
ist im Moment zu hoch es kann nicht
bleiben wie
bisher die Not in den Kommunen ist groß
von einer gewissen Dramatik spricht der
Vizekanzler als hätte er zum ersten Mal
die Augen geöffnet kommt jetzt noch eine
Zeitenwende die EU haben sich gestern
auf den letzten Punkt der asylreform
geeinigt die wird irreguläre Migration
wirksam begrenzen das behauptet der
Kanzler die Grünen bezweifelten
das Friedrich mer die Grünen ohnehin als
Bremsklotz und bietet dem Kanzler einen
deutschlandpakt an wenn Sie es mit den
Grünen nicht hinbekommen dann werfen Sie
sie raus dann machen wir es aber wir
müsen
diesesen Führer der Unionsfraktion die
CDU Herr frei bietet
einen migrationspakt an ist das mit
dieser Einigung von gestern in Brüssel
bezüglich der
eu-asylreform ist das damit hinfällig
nein überhaupt nicht denn man muss es ja
mal einordnen gestern haben sich die 27
Mitgliedstaaten der Europäischen Union
geeinigt daraus wird noch kein
europäisches Regelwerk dazu Bedarfes der
Beteiligung des Europäischen Parlamentes
und klar ist auch dass wenn sie sich die
einzelnen Maßnahmen anschauen dann sehen
Sie das wirkt vielleicht in Z Jahren in
di Jahren da ist ja Aufbauleistung
notwendig und vor diesem Hintergrund
nein das das was dort vereinbart wurde
wird nicht ab jetzt wirken und das
bedeutet im Klartext nationale Maßnahmen
werden weiter notwendig sein und
deswegen wird werden wir hier in
Deutschland handeln müssen und Friedrich
MZ und sie sehnen sich nach einer großen
Koalition her nein es ist halt einfach
so dass das Beschreiben der Probleme im
Bereich der Migration noch kein Problem
löst sondern es ist eine gewaltige
Herausforderung der Befund des
Bundeskanzlers ist zutreffend die
Herausforderung war wahrscheinlich noch
nie so groß wie heute und wir erleben ja
was es mit der Bevölkerung auch macht
wir erleben eine Polarisierung wir
erleben
Ohnmachtsgefühle wir erleben staatlichen
Kontrollverlust und vor diesem
Hintergrund ist es glaube ich ganz
entscheidend dass man die
Gemeinsamkeiten sucht wo sie vorhanden
sind im Sinne einer Lösungsfindung da
haben wir ganz viele schöne S schon
gehört und werden untergarantie auf
einige davon zurückkommen aus Frankfurt
zugeschaltet heute weil Wahlkampftermine
ist uns omit nuripur einer der zwei
Parteichefs der Grünen Herr nuipo sie
sagen es hat kein Machtwort des Kanzlers
gegeben es war nicht nötig um zu dieser
Verständigung in Brüssel mit den anderen
EU-Staaten zu kommen war es deshalb
nicht nötig weil die Grünen auf ihre
letzten Überzeugungen verzichtet haben
und zwar
freiwillig es gab eine große
Übereinkunft in der Koalition dass die
ursprüngliche Version der einen
Verordnung in der asylreform der
Europäischen Union also die sogenannte
krisenverordnung eine chaosverordnung
war weil es da drinne festgelegt war
dass wenn ein Land Krise ruft dass dann
auf Registrierung auf Standards jegliche
Art verzichtet werden kann aber es war
ja nur ein Teil es war ja nur ein Teil
dieser Reform insgesamt sind fünf
verschiedene Punkte geeinord ist richtig
aber das ging jetzt um diese eine
Verordnung in Brüssel und da waren wir
uns alle einig dass sie so nicht bleiben
kann und es ist jetzt verhandelt worden
ist auch gut so und es ist nicht mehr so
dass die Staaten einach Krise rufen und
alle Standards aussetzen weil das hätte
natürlich auch dazu geführt dass Länder
z.B ein Mittelmeer die Leute noch noch
verlässlicher in Anführungsstrichen
durchgelassen hätten und die wären nach
Deutschland gekommen und die Belastung
für die kommun wä größer geworden und
deshalb wollten wir die verändern und es
haben auch geschafft das verhindern Sie
jetzt und das werden sie ihrer grünen
Basis dann genauso lässig erklären wie
uns gerade
äh es geht darum dass wir Humanität und
Ordnung brauchen die Verhältnisse der
Zeit an den Außengrenzen sind weder
Humanität noch Ordnung wenn die Leute
auf griechischen Inseln fest stecken
eineinhalb zwei Jahre auf müllhalten
Leben und nicht mal ihr Asylantrag
behandelt wird ist es schlecht für die
Inseln für die Leute die da Leben es ist
schlecht für Griechenland es ist
schlecht für die EU und für die Leute um
die es geht und dementsprechen braucht
es das und es braucht natürlich auch am
Ende des Tages mehr Solidarität in der
Europäischen Union bei der Verteilung
und die Gesamtreform und Sie haben Recht
die krisenverordnung ist nur eine ein
ein ein kleiner Teil dessen äh
beinhaltet auch dass die Frage z.B von
grenzverfahren gekoppelt ist daran dass
Staaten auch die Verteilung mitmachen
müssen das ist exakt ein weiterer Punkt
den wir heute besprechen wollen und sind
erstmal bei der politischen Analyse und
dankbar dass Anja Meer bei uns ist vom
Fokus lange bei der Tatz jetzt für den
Fokus Arbeiten denkend und schreibend
ähm Klimaschutz war schon so eine erste
Rakete hat dieses Thema Migration dieses
Thema Asyl tatsächlich die Kraft die
Ampel auch zu zersprengen in erster
Linie würde ich sagen hat es erstmal die
Kraft die Grünen unter Spann
Hochspannung zu setzen ich kann mich
noch erinnern an den Kompromiss vom Juni
da war ich beim Sommerempfang der Grünen
da war glaube ich gerade 30 Jahre oder
40 Jahre Herr nu muss es genau wissen
in so einer schicken
Location hier in Berlin und da waren die
ganzen jungen Abgeordneten der Grünen
Vorort dies die haben fast geweint also
die haben haben sich mit keinen
Journalisten gesprochen weil sie sonst
hätten einfach Weinen zu geboden gehen
müssen und die waren richtig sauer und
dieser diese Einigung die die wir jetzt
gerade erleben ist natürlich sozusagen
noch top also on top dazu ja und Herr
nugipor hat ja heute auch gerade einen
schönen Brief bekommen von der
Bundesarbeitsgemeinschaft Migration und
Flüchtlinge die seiner Partei die jetzt
das klingt so ein bisschen nach
kleingartenvererein aber das ist eine
enorm wichtige
Geschichte innerhalb der Grünen
und die richtig
Zunder machen gerade also und Frage
Grünen haben im November Parteitag da
freue ich mich schon drauf die Grünen
haben im November Parteitag wird es ihre
Partei in dieser Frage
zerreißen ich bin ein wenig irritiert
muss ich zugeben wir reden über eine
unglaublich große Frage für alle wir
reden davon wie wir Steuerung
reinbekommen wir reden davon wie wir die
Kommunen entlasten wir reden davon wie
wir jetzt dieser Situation her werden
und wir reden z.B davon dass wir doch
alle doch Interesse daran haben sollten
wenn wir ein Herz haben dass die Leute
nicht verrecken im Mittelmeer und dass
man da schwierige Wege gehen darf und
muss ist richtig dass es nicht die eine
Lösung gibt wo man mit Finger schnips
und da gibt's Lösungen auch ich weiß
nicht warum es jetzt heißt die Grünen
tun sich schwer ich weiß nicht wer sich
nicht schwer tut ich weiß nur dass es
Leute gibt die eben Wochentag
irgendwelche Ideen auf dem Weg bringen
die nicht funktionieren oder nicht
rechtens sind wir werden dem
für all das eine Antwort geben müssen
viele Antworten geben müssen und das
machen wir in der Bundesregierung in der
Koalition miteinander und ehrlich gesagt
wer sich an der Stelle nicht schwer tut
da hat das Problem nicht verstanden die
Grünen sind auf dem Weg zu einer
Begrenzung der Zuwanderung ein Hindernis
das sagte
eben die FDP und zwar Herr der
Generalsekretär Herr jisarei und wir
erinnern uns an den
Satz die Grünen sind in der pitik ein
Sicherheitsrisiko für das Land und
erschweren durch realitätsferne
Positionen konsequentes
Regierungshandeln es ist eben nicht nur
eine Frage an die Grünen der nipur
sondern es ist auch eine Frage für die
Ampel ich will jetzt wirklich nicht für
einzelne Leute in der FDP sprechen ich
kann nur zusagen dass ich sehr sehr
viele SMS gekriegt habe von
Entschuldigungsschreiben die für Leute
die sich geschämt haben für diese Art
des Umganges und es sind einzelleute
aber eigentlich plegen wir einen solchen
Umgang in der Ampel miteinander nicht
wir arbeiten zusammen dass wir die
Probleme hinbekommen dass wir die Lösung
hinbekommen miteinander und wir reden
sehr viel miteinander ich kann allen nur
empfehlen dass den Ton ein bisschen
reduzieren weil gerade in einer
sehr verunsicherten Gesellschaft ist es
nicht hilfreich wenn wir als Politik
immer wilder mit mit Sprüchen um uns
schmeißen her frei hat gerade davon
gesprochen es gäbe staatliche
staatlichen Kontrollverlust ich weiß
nicht wo er lebt da wo ich le lebe ist
es nicht so es gibt eine riesige
Herausforderung für viele Kommunen äh
und den müssen wir helfen und wir müssen
natürlich auch schauen dass wir die
Steuerung reinbekommen und die Mehrheit
der Leute in diesem Land die haben ja
sehr viel Empathie für für für die Frage
wie man mit den Leuten umgeht wie man
hilft denen die vor Bomben fliehen
beispielsweise und dementsprechend kann
ich alle nur auffordern lasst uns
zusammen an den Lösungen arbeiten und
nicht immer nur auf die hauen und sagen
wer schuld istür sind dafür sind wir
heute hier bei uns ist der Ober
Bürgermeister von Kiel Herr Kämpfer sie
haben wie viele Menschen in ihrer Stadt
zu wohnen also wir haben über die
letzten Jahre insgesamt 8000 Menschen
auf FL ne ich meinte Einwohner
entschuigung knapp 250 000 250 000 sie
haben wie viele in den letzten zwei
Jahren an Flüchtlingen dazuekommen also
letzten zwei Jahren wahrscheinlich 5000
und wenn sie dem Kanzler zuhören der in
derselben Partei ist wie sie sie sind
für die SPD Oberbürgermeister in Kiel äh
dass das zu viele Menschen sind äh die
da momentan nach Deutschland kommen und
70% von ihnen wollen nach Deutschland
und sind
unregistriert warum versteht ihr das
erst jetzt fragen Sie sich das auch nein
das frage ich mich nicht ich glaube dass
der Kanzler das schon alles auch im
lilick hat der war selber Bürgermeister
aber wir kommen in eine Situation im
Moment wir haben es glaube ich sehr
lange gut abgefedert was ja auch
durchaus an Unordnung im System ist und
ich finde das ist großartig gelaufen mit
den ukrainischen geflüchteten letztes J
ja viel geräuschloser als wir das 2015
2016 hatten aber jetzt wird es langsam
eben noch wir sind noch nicht beim
Kontrollverlust aber wir sind jetzt in
einer Situation wo ich ja weiß also ich
bekomme jetzt die nächsten vier Wochen
jede Woche 50 geflüchtete ähm und ich
weiß noch so 150 Plätze so eigentlich
bin ich voll aber wir fangen jetzt an in
den großen
Gemeinschaftsunterkünften zu verdichten
ja das ist nicht integrationsförderlich
das ist nicht gut ich habe Familien wo
ich jetzt sage Familien mit mit zwei
Kindern die die habe ich jetzt
vielleicht noch im Sechsbettzimmer weil
die das brauchen und jetzt muss ich
sagen ne dann müsst ihr ausziehen ich
brauche die sechs betetten für andere
ihr müsst euch verkleinern also wir
schaffen noch ein paar Wochen was aber
danach laufen wir auch an Antworten
langsam noch mal die Frage sind sie
rechtzeitig gehört worden auch in
Schleswig-Holstein werden jetzt
brandbriefe an die Regierung geschrieben
in nach Berlin sind die ohnehin schon
seit Monaten unterwegs Stichwort
Ukrainer 1 Million ukrainische
Flüchtlinge sind in diesem Land und das
wird nicht immer mit dazu gesagt
m aserber in Deutchland plus diese über
eine Million ukrainischen Flüchtlinge
unsere Überlastung kommt also nicht nur
wegen des Asylgesetzes natlich nicht ist
das fair den Flüchtlingen den
Asylbewerbern gegenüber es geht dabei
nicht um FIS aber die Beschreibung ist
absolut richtig wir hten eine ganz
andere Situation wenn es in Ukraine
Krieg nicht gebe nicht nur in ganz
anderen vielen Hinsichten aber auch was
den Druck und die Möglichkeiten der
kommun angeht aber sie sind ja da
deswegen Jahreszahlen alleine sagen
wenig aus weil die vom letzten und vom
vorletzten sind auch noch alle da und da
wird es und es kann ja nicht ich kann
natürlich noch jede Menge Turnhallen und
zellstäter richten nur das ist nicht das
was wir ja unser humanitären
Verpflichtung wegen unser rechtlichen
Verpflichtung und auch der
integrationswegen die Lösung sein kann
so auch für die Schüler dass die ganzen
aber das da kommen wir vielleicht noch
dazu aber alleine das zeigt schon die
Luft wird da jetzt sehr sehr dünn das
ist in der einen Kommune vielleicht
früher als in der anderen aber wir
brauchen Atempause und wir brauchen
glaube ich auch einen gamechanger und
keine Scheinlösung wie sie jetzt aller
Orten thematisiert wer könnte dieser
gamechanger sein also der der eben der
magische Punkt der das Ruder herumreißt
Rü kupmansn ist bei uns auch in dieser
Sendung das finden wir gut so
Migrationsforscher hier an der Humbold
Universität in Berlin Herr
kopmn kommt diese Erkenntnis jetzt zu
spät kommt diese Einigung in Europa zu
spät messen Sie der welche Bedeutung bei
das sind jetzt zu viele Fragen auf
einmal
ich versuch zu ordnen und meine erste
wäre wird diese Einigung da in Brüssel
etwas an der Belastung in Deutschland
ändern
ja die Einigung kommt zu spät um erstmal
auf ihre erste Frage zu antworten wir
hatten natürlich eigentlich von 2016 bis
2022 eine längere Zeit wo die
Flüchtlingszahlen relativ niedrig waren
und diese Zeit hat die EU hat auch
Deutschland einfach vergehen lassen ohne
zu handeln das hat di Bundesregierung
gemacht aber auch die vorige
Bundesregierung hat das gemacht also
jetzt müssen wieder wir wieder unter äh
Druck handeln und da wird natürlich
teilweise auch mit heißen Nadel Nadeln
gestrickt wie bei dem Tunesien Deal in
im Juni also dieses Abkommen äh kann äh
der Anfang sein von einer Lösung äh es
kann aber auch äh zu eins zwei viele
Morias führen
und ob es das eine oder das andere sein
wird hängt davon ab was die
Folgeschritten sind also was wir
brauchen jetzt als Folgeschritt ist eine
Offensive von Verhandlungen mit
Drittstaaten weil das ganze versprechen
dieses Abkommen ist dass die Menschen
die dann in den grenzverfahren abgelehnt
werden zügig zurückgeführt werden
entweder in den Herkunftsländern oder in
sicheren Drittstaaten aber wenn wir
keine Abkommen haben mit diesen Staaten
wird es nicht gelingen dann wird sich
werden sich diese Leute stauen da in in
den grenzlagern und dann wird das zu
moriaartige Zustände führen also nur
wenn die zügige Rückführung gelingt und
die gelingt nur in Zusammenarbeit mit
Drittstaaten werden wir weiterkommen und
das ist denke ich wo die prioritätten
liegen sollte und zwar jetzt weil wie
Herr frei schon gesagt hat es wird noch
mindestens zwei Jahre dauern wie das
angenommen von Europaparlament da wird
bestimmt auch noch einiges geändert dann
muss es noch alles umgesetzt werden also
das heißt wir brauchen vorher eigentlich
diese Bi und trilateralen Verträge wir
werden darüber gleich reden wichtig ist
vielleicht an diesem Tisch erstmal zu
klären was hier in Deutschland in der
Zwischenzeit passiert denn es hat ja
auch in der Atmosphäre eine unangenehme
Aufheizung gegeben Frau Meer wenn ich
das so noch mal weiter Frage zu ihnen äh
wie empfinden wie definieren Sie der Ton
in den Ton in dem wir unterwegs sind die
Atmosphäre in der diskutiert wird warten
wir jetzt am besten bis die Wahlen
vorbei sind am Wochenende hat es damit
was zu tun Fall was mit mit den
Landtagswahlen am Wochenende zu tun aber
es sind ja quasi immer irgendwie
Landtagswahlen und Europawahl haben wir
ja auch bald und so weiter ja also
das ist schon wahr aber wir sind
natürlich auch glaube ich
das wird jetzt Herr nuripo nicht
gefallen aber ich glaube die Ampel macht
ein derart uneinigen Eindruck
auch wenn jetzt diesmal der FDP
Generalsekretär sich da im Ton
vergriffen hat
dass die Union ein leichtes Spiel hat
dieses Feld zu bewirtschaften also sie
sie hat ja z.B einfach diesen Pakt um
umetikettiert eigentlich sollte es da um
Verwaltungsvereinfachung und Prozess
Prozess Management gehen und die Union
hat gesagt ne wir machen was anderes als
würde sie mitregieren gleichzeitig ist
dieses Angebot aus meiner Sicht
ein Fake Angebot weil natürlich na ja
weil sie sind in der Opposition sie
bewirtschaften das Feld der Opposition
und sie wollen natürlich auf gar keinen
Fall
vergleichbar und ähnlich werden den
regierenden Parteien sie müssen sich ja
auch irgendwie ab setzen ja nee wir
haben ganz konkrete Vorstellungen wie
man es machen könnte und wir können uns
natürlich nur auf eine Vereinbarung
einlassen die im Ergebnis zu weniger
Migration führt also auch Herr nuripur
hat ja mehrfach von Steuerung und auch
von Ordnung gesprochen er hat das Wort
Begrenzung nicht in den Mund genommen
das halte ich aber für zwingend
notwendig noch interessanter formuliert
übrigens ihr parteichf Friedrich Merz
der teilt im Grunde auch in alle
Richtungen aus also da trifft es den
ukrainischen sozialtouristen und und es
trifft den kleinen Pascha aus dem
arabischen Raum und es traf jetzt den
sich Zahnersatz organisierenden
Asylbewerber
wenn Sie eine sachliche Diskussion
wollen Herr frei glauben Sie dass das
zuträglich ist also ich glaube wenn man
sachlich diskutieren will dann darf man
vor allem nicht alles durcheinander
werfen er hat sich er hat sich für den
sozialtourismus am Tag darauf
entschuldigt oder sogar am gleichen Tag
noch und was er im Bereich der
medizinischen Versorgung gesagt hat hat
er jedenfalls richtig argumentiert wir
haben doch tatsächlich die Situation er
hat ja von abgelehnten Asylbewerbern
gesprochen abgelehnte Asylbewerber sind
alle länger als 18 Monate in Deutschland
in der Regel nach Abschluss des
verwaltungsgerichtsverfahrens sind die
knapp 3 Jahre in Deutschland im
Durchschnitt und das bedeutet wir sind
das einzige Land in Europa wo man als
abgelehnter Asylbewerber höhere
Leistungen bekommt als wenn man als
schutzsuchender hierher kommt und es ist
doch auch nicht akzeptabel nein
vielleicht den Satz noch es ist doch
auch nicht akzeptabel dass man als
abgelehnter Asylbewerber also kein
Flüchtling sondern ein Migrant der das
Land verlassen muss die vollen
Leistungen wie ein Kassenpatient bekommt
kann do nicht sind die Leistungen der
Kassenpatienten jetzt auch nicht also
ich meine der geht's doch hier nicht um
jacketcron es geht um eine Versorgung
eine Grundversorgung med nein da geht es
schon um mehr als eine Grundversorgung
also vielleicht auch eine Füllung bei
aller bei aller Liebe nein aber Sie
müssen sie dürfen doch nicht die Augen
davor verschließen als das ist wenn sie
an der Infrastruktur nichts verändern
und wenn sie die Zahl der
Leistungsberechtigten permanent
ausweiten das gilt ja wir haben drüber
gesprochen nicht nur für Asylbewerber es
gilt auch für Ukrainer dass sie dann an
Kapazitätsgrenzen stoßen ist doch
offensichtlich also die interessante
Frage ist ja die die interessante Frage
ist ja die mit welchem subson man
spricht oder mit welchem Dünkel indem
man eben immer sagt hier gibt's die
Deutschen und hier gibt's die
Asylbewerber und das macht Friederich
märz nicht zum ersten Mal dass er
Vergleich zwischen den deutschen und dem
was denen zusteht und dem was
Asylbewerbern zusteht aber
Entschuldigung Frau ner es macht doch
ein Unterschied ob sie hierher ins Land
kommen oder ob sie seit Jahren in ihre
Krankenkasse einbezahlen also wer sagt
denn das aber es sind ja es sind ja
deutsche Gesetze also es wäre ja dann
ein Vorwurf an uns selbst und so stellt
er es da als einen Vorwurf an die
Menschen die hier in das Land kommen
nein genau und das muss man nicht tun
also man könnte wie die
genau s den Kern dieses wunderbarsten
Asylgesetzes das es in der Welt gibt
gilt es zu schützen hätte man auch sagen
wen na ja gut es geht jetzt hier um eine
andere Frage aber sie haben insofern
vollkommen recht es ist natürlich nicht
denenen Vorwurf zu machen die das Recht
das sie haben nutzen sondern ist ein
Vorwurf uns zu machen dass wir Gesetze
haben die im Grunde genommen die
falschen Signale in die Welt sen absolut
nur weil sie fragten weshalb ich nach
dem Ton Frage nach dem Thron der
Diskussion und Frage auch ganz kurz noch
mal den Oberbürgermeister aus Kiel ob
und wie groß eigentlich seine Probleme
mit der Zahnarztbehandlung sind von also
weder meine privaten noch sonst
irgendwie sind irgendwie von Migration
bisher beinflusst gewesen und ich glaube
auch nicht dass es ein Merz darum GEG
einen konstruktiven Beitrag jetzt zu
unserer Problem zu leisten son es ging
um Stimmungsmache und darum irgendwie
das Gefühl von Ungerechtigkeit und die
kriegensjahr und wo bleib denn ich und
das ist glaube ich wirklich völlig
unproduktiv die die realen Probleme sind
ja groß genug um noch so zu tun als se
das der Kern der Debatte und da müssen
wir über anderes reden und deswegen ist
das glaube ich schon ziemlich fatal
solche Nebelkerzen so werfen auch wieder
eine Scheinlösung noch nicht mal eine
Lösung ein nur eine Stimmungsmache um
sozusagen das zu spalten und eine
Stimmung zu machen die die Probleme
lassen Sie auch über die echten Probleme
reden um dann zu gucken was könn echte
Lösung dafür sein hat Lösungsvorschlag
gemacht in der Sache deswegen keine
Nebelkerze dann sind kommen wir noch
dazu ist versprochen dann sind wir eben
genau bei der Frage gibt es einen Sa
lichen Kern was würde der
Oberbürgermeister von Kiel sagen warum
ist es für Migranten so attraktiv nach
Deutschland zu kommen sind wir
attraktiver als andere Länder ja ganz
offen Grundig sind wir das sonst würden
wir nicht die Hauptlast sage ich mal der
Migration in Europa Schultern und das
ist sich kein Zufall dass sie nicht alle
nach Albanien gehen sondern weil wir ein
Sozialstaat sind weil wir ein ein
Demokratie sind weil wir Stabilität
haben all das was diese Menschen in
ihren Heimatländern nicht haben ja also
zunächst mal gibt's wahnsinnig viele
pushfaktoren dass Menschen aus Ländern
kommen wo sie politisch erfolgt werden
wo es Bürgerkrieg gibt oder wo es
einfach Elend und keine Perspektive gibt
und wir alle an deren Stelle würden
wahrscheinlich sagen wenn ich daraus ein
Ausweg finde dann suche ich den so und
dann gucke ich natürlich wenn ich ein
Push habe wo ist es dann vielleicht für
mich am besten und das ist jetzt erstmal
nicht schlimmes wenn man dann sagt
deutschland ist ein Land da kann ich mir
in Zukunft vorstellen dass das für uns
eine Überforderungssituation ergeben
kann und darauf laufen wir gerade hinaus
und dass wir eine gerechte Verteilung in
in Europa waren und so weiter alles
völlig klar aber wenn ich allein an das
Existenzminimum denke das ist
verfassungsrechtlich geschützt da werden
wir niemals uns auf albanische oder was
auch immer Verhältnisse runterbieen
wollen das wird nicht funktionieren also
kann das auch nicht der Schlüssel sein
und ich glaube doch keiner hier am Tisch
dass wenn dann nach 3 Jahren ich
abgelehnt habeülbewerber bin und mein
Verfahren hängt am verwaltungsricht wenn
dann ich keine blomme mehr bekomme
sondern nurch ein Spritze dass das jetzt
der Schlüssel ist dass wir das
Migrationsproblem lösen das kann doch
keiner wirklich meinen dennoch sind wir
bei der Frage und der Suche nach einer
sachlichen Antwort auf die Frage ob und
an welchen Stellen Deutschland besonders
attraktiv ist auch in Bezug auf das
Angebot an
geflüchtete Asylsuchende in Deutschland
erhalten Leistungen nach dem
Asylbewerber
leistungsgesetz dazu gehören
medizinische auch zahnärztliche
Leistungen wenn sie unaufschiebbar sind
aber nach 18 Monaten Aufenthalt haben
Schutzsuchende auch abgelehnte
Asylbewerber Anspruch auf Leistungen die
in Art und Höhe denen der Sozialhilfe
entsprechen sie werden analog behandelt
wie Versicherte in der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung auch diese
analogleistung Macht Deutschland in
Europa attraktiver als andere
EU-Mitglieder in Frankreich gibt es nach
Ablehnung des Asylantrags keinen
Anspruch mehr auf Leistungen und
medizinische g nur in
Notfällen Griechenland gewährt bis zur
Ausreise nur Unterkunft und Verpflegung
Ärzte helfen in lebensbedrohlichen
Situationen
ähnlich ist es auch in Dänemark wo
abgelehnte Asylbewerber nur bis zur
Abreise versorgt werden aber keine
Geldleistungen mehr
erhalten deutschland ist das einzige
Land in der EU das Schutzsuchende
dauerhaft mit Sozialleistungen
ausstattet und zwar soange wie sie im
Land bleiben auch wenn ihr Asylgesuch
abgelehnt
wurde so das sind die Fakten und hier
ist die Frage an Herrn kopmansn hat der
deutsche Staat derzeit das attraktivste
Angebot für geflüchtete in Europa na ja
ganz offensichtliche das wurde vorher
schon gesagt also die Flüchtlinge
stimmen natürlich auch mit den Füßen ab
also die Tatsache dass sie viel öfter
nicht nur nach Deutschland als nach
Albanien gehen aber auch öfter nach
Deutschland als nach vielen der
Nachbarländer Frankreich z.B oder
Dänemark hat natürlich damit zu tun dass
es für
Schutzsuchende attraktiver ist nach
Deutschland zu kommen und vor allem auch
für diese Gruppe von Menschen die auch
von sich selbst wissen dass sie
wahrscheinlich abgelehnt werden weil sie
aus Länder stammen wo es keine
politische Verfolgung gibto kein
Bürgerkrieg herrscht und dann ist es
natürlich attraktiver um nach
Deutschland zu gehen so und damit ist
die Frage noch mal nach Frankfurt bei
Omid nuripur was wenn Herr märz also in
der der Sache tatsächlich recht hat und
nach 18 Monaten ein auch abgelehnter
Asylbewerber eine höhere eben analoge
Leistung in Deutschland bekommt würden
Sie sagen dass man an dieser Situation
etwas ändern muss Herr norip ja zwei
Dinge das eine ist dass es zwingend
notwendig ist drauf zu schauen wovon
diese Leute leben und wir haben einen
massiven Mangel an Arbeitskräften auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt und ich kann niemandem
erklären warum erfahrene
Krankenschwestern K die Frage
beantworten herro wir kommen noch zum
arbeitsm wir reden gerne aber der
Lebensunterhalt der Leute ist doch der
Grund warum wir über das reden und der
der Oberbürgermeister von Kiel und das
war der andere Punkt gewesen hat völlig
zurecht darauf hingewiesen dass wir hier
über verfassungsgüter reden also Güter
in Verfassungsrang sprechen Herr frei
hat vor drei Monaten erklärt ich
behaupte mal aus Angst vor vor vor vor
der AFD wir müssen jetzt mal ein
Grundrecht ab schaffen wir sollten
unsere Verfassung jetzt nicht
verstümmeln weil wir glauben dass wir
dass wir jetzt Angst haben müssen vor
vor vor der AFD sondern wir sollten uns
um die Probleme kümmern noch mal der
entscheidende Punkt ist die
LE aber die Leute wenn die Leute
arbeiten dürfen dann dann dann gibt es
dieses diese Thematik doch gar nicht
dann leben sie von ihrer eigenen
Arbeitshand über die
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten über die
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten werden wir noch
reden aber noch ich sag's ja noch ist es
eine deutsche gesetzgeb dass nach 18
Monaten ein Asylbewerber der sogar
abgelehnt ist in ein höheres
gesundheitsbetreuungsrecht fällt der
Vorschlag der Union ist ein ganz klarer
Herr frei sie wollten ihnen schon sagen
sie möchten diese Zeit verlängern sie
möchten aus 18 Monaten 36 Monate machen
und sie sind Verwaltungsjurist und
glauben auch dass das durchgeht ja also
wenn man sich die die Rechtssprechung
des Bundesverfassungsgerichts von 2012
anschaut die ist da einschlägig dann bin
ich davon überzeugt dass 36 Monate vom
Verfassungsgericht noch akzeptiert
würden aber darf ich noch auf einen
Punkt Hinweisen es gibt ja nicht nur die
sozialen und wirtschaftlichen Leistungen
die Deutschland attraktiver machen wenn
man sich beispielsweise die
Möglichkeiten des Familiennachzugs
anschaut sind die in Deutschland
attraktiver als in Frankreich oder in
Österreich das macht uns natürlich auch
attraktiver wir haben mit dem
chancenaufenthaltsgesetz die Möglichkeit
des Spurwechsels was bedeutet es wir
senden das Signal in die Welt wenn du es
nach Deutschland gchafft hast kannst du
wenn du nicht straffällig geworden bist
auch hier bleiben und damit sind wir
natürlich schon mit diesen gesetzlichen
Rahmenbedingungen viel attraktiver als
praktisch jedes andere Land in Europa
und die Summe daraus macht es genauso
wie es auch nicht den einen Hebel gibt
um dieses Problem zu bewältigen ich
glaube das sagt auch kein vernünftiger
Mensch sondern es wird wenn man im
System bleibt eine ganze Reihe von Maß
Ben sie als Diskussion ja an Herr fre
das ist aber Teil einer eines ma
das alleine löst das Problem natürlich
ja aber das wird ja diskutiert und Sie
möchten ja offensichtlich in der
politischen Debatte auch was bewegen und
möchten ja nicht nur themenhopping
machen und dann sind wir wieder bei Frau
Meer und Fragen Frau Meer ob dieser
deutsche Sozialstaat nur überlebt wenn
er in Bezug auf seine Flüchtlinge ein
Sozialstaat Leid wird nee das glaube ich
nicht ich glaube dass man auch ein
bisschen wir können auch ein bisschen
stolz darauf sein dass wir kein
inhumanes Land sind und dass Menschen
bei uns zum Arzt gehen können und dass
die LE
auch respektvoll behandelt werden in
diesem Land das finde ich erstmal nicht
verkehrt ich glaube es ist an der
Politik an der Bundespolitik und in
Zusammenarbeit mit den Ländern wo es
übrigens auch total hakt nach nach allem
was ich höre diese Zuwanderung zu
regulieren das ist einfach glaube ich
also das ist glaube ich ihr Problem was
sie da haben Vorort sie machen mir jetzt
nicht den Eindruck als hätten Sie Lust
den Leuten den HA abzudrehen und sie
nicht mehr zum Arzt lassen zu wollen
oder so sondern es geht darum dass also
das was wir dass jeder Bürger jede
Bürgerin und auch ein Zuwanderer von der
Politik erwarten kann ich zahle meine
Steuern ich werde nicht kriminell ich äh
bin lebe mein Leben nach allen Regeln
und ihr kümmert euch darum dass hier der
Laden läuft und das passiert im Moment
nicht und in diese Bresche kann die
Union ganz leicht rein jederzeit mit
noch einer Forderung heute ist es wieder
mal dass sie jetzt doch nicht arbeiten
sollen die geflüchteten und so also es
sind zwei zwei interessante Punkte die
wir noch durchsprechen müssen weil sie
eben in der politischen Debatte sind das
nächste ist die Chipkarte Herr kupmansn
es wird gerade gesagt dass die Bezüge
die Asylbewerber und Flüchtlinge
bekommen eben nicht mehr als Bargeld
ausgezahlt wird heißt diskutiert Herr
Lindner aus der Koalition die FDP macht
sich stark dafür dass es dafür eine
schipkarte gibt glauben sie denken sie
dass das ein guter Gedanke ist kann man
den zumuten ja oder nein sollte man ihn
einführen ich glaube schon dass das
Wirkung erzielen kann weil ähm die
Entscheidung um nach Europa zu migrieren
oder um nach Deutschland zu migrieren
oft keine individuelle Entscheidung ist
sondern Entscheidung die getroffen wird
von ganzen Familien es sind oft Familien
die das Geld zusammenbringen um einen
jungen Mann auf die Reise zu schicken
und diese Investierung die Familien
machen da gibt's auch eine Erwartung
dass sie zurückgezahlt wird dass Geld
zurückgeschickt wird in die Heimatländer
und wenn das nicht mehr möglich ist
indem man eine Chipkarte hat das Geld
ist ja auch nicht für gemeint um
zurückzuschicken in die Heimat sondern
für die Grundversorgung hier wenn man
diese Grundversorgung leistet in Form
einer Karte mit dem man tatsächlich das
kaufen kann was man braucht und was das
Bundesverfassungsgericht fordert dann
kann man kein Geld nach Hause schicke
von dies auch schon möglich und das wird
natürlich die Anreize um nach Europa
oder dann in diesem Fall dann
Deutschland zu wählen natürlich abnehmen
lassen und da setzt sich nun der
Bundesfinanzminister außerordentlich für
ein die FDP ohnehin würden Sie sagen
Herr Kämpfer dass das ein Unterschied
machte können sie es überhaupt gibt ja
viele die sagen das ist um Himmels
willen ist viel zu aufwendig also
erstens es ist schon möglich ja das ist
jetzt keine Sache die die bundesre jetzt
entscheiden muss sondern das kann vor
Ort entschieden werden und es ist man
kann sich darüber unterhalten ja ob das
irgendwelche kleine Effekte hat oder
nicht aber es ist ganz bestimmt nicht
der gamechanger wo wir sagen dann wird
sich das Problem in Luft auslösen auch
nicht mal ansatzweise und es ist kein zu
und es gibt auch und es gibt auch kein
es ist auch kein Zufall dass egal wel ob
der Oberbürgermeister von welcher Partei
ist oder was ist das ist im Moment ich
kenne keine einzige Kommune wo das
passiert weil warum ist das so entweder
ich muss ist unglaublich bürokratisch
machen das heißt die dürfen nur
bestimmte warngruppen haben ähm und ich
muss das dann alles doch noch
kontrollieren das macht keine Kommune
wir haben alle wirklich über die Ohren
zu tun mit den Basisaufgaben der
Integration oder ich gebe den eine
Chipkarte und dann können sie doch beim
Revo oder sonst wo einkaufen und dann
wenn es dann wirklich so ist wie sie
sagen ja dann kaufen die Hal Zigaretten
und Schnaps und irgendwas was ich weiter
verkaufen lässt das kann ich überhaupt
nicht kontrollieren das löst das Problem
auch nicht das ist dann eine gewisse
kleine Unbequemlichkeit und so weiter
man kann über sowas diskutieren was mich
nur wahnsinnig stört ist ja ich habe
ganz andere Probleme und das immer so
getan wird heute ist es der dann ist es
der dann das ist als das Grundgesetz das
Asylrecht die Chipkarte weder kurz und
ich glaube auch nicht mittel und
langfristig löst das mein Problem dass
ich eine besser planbare eine
gesteuertere verlässliche Migration
brauch wir wollen ja unseren humanitären
Verpflichtung nachkommen wir wollen die
Leute integrieren ich bin auch keiner
diese also 600 000 glaube ich haben wir
bis zum Juni in in Europa an
geflüchteten bekommen ja wenn wir die
gut verteilen würden dann können wir die
auch integrieren nur sie werden nicht
gut verteilt und das gleiche gilt eben
auch für Deutschland dass sie sozusagen
dann in Wellen kommen und dafür brauchen
wir einen Ansatz und ich habe davon noch
überhaupt kein Gehör das wird doch auch
gar nicht wir das ist eine reine
Illusion und die wird im übrigen auch
nicht bei uns eden also Länder nicht nur
wie Polen und Ungarn auch Österreich
Dänemark Schweden die werden niemals
diese Umverteilung mitmachen vor der sie
sprechen und deswegen glaube ich wer
darauf wartet der wartet auf den ST
nimmerlein und deswegen geht deswegen
geht's doch darum dass wir die Probleme
hier lösen und schauen Sie Herr gämpfer
wenn derzeit 700 Asylanträge pro Tag
gestellt werden dann ist es der
Kontrollverlust von dem ich gesprochen
habe weil wenn morgen 800 dort kommen
dann kann und macht die Bundesregierung
auch nichts dagegen und die Probleme
werden immer bei ihnen landen die Länder
werden Puffer sein länger oder kürzer je
nachdem wie gut sie ihre Aufgabe machen
am Ende landet es bei ihnen in der Stadt
und sie müssen mit dem umgehen was da
ist und wir versuchen das ist ja jetzt
nur die Frage wird der politische
Versuch Deutschland darin bestehen im
Grunde es den Flüchtlingen immer
unangenehmer in Deutschland zu machen
also nur damit wir das auch von Ihnen
hören Herr Freis sagen sie nur noch
Sachleistungen für die Flüchtlinge sagen
sie wie Herr Lindner endlich die
schipkarte damit wir nicht mehr Geld h
ich halte das für richtig und ich würde
es auch für richtig halten wenn es dazu
eine bundländervereinbarung gäbe weil es
hilft natürlich nichts wenn diese
Chipkarte in einzelnen Städten oder in
einzelnen Ländern eingeführt würde das
würde dann eine Wirkung und auch nur
eine teilwirkung entfalten wenn das
flächendeckend in Deutschland der Fall
werden ich will nicht ich will nicht
dass überhaupt
nein seine gesundheitter digitalisiert
bekommen hat möchte jetzt
plötzlich man sollte über konstruktive
Vorschläge nachdenken wie sie zu einer
Begrenzung kommen sonst werden sie all
diese Probleme nicht lösen denn die
Probleme sind doch klar die Wohnungen
fehlen doch in Deutschland die
Erzieherin und Erzieher fehlen die
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer fehlen was haben
Sie denn da für Vorschläge aber diese
Kontroll
ich gerne dass wir die Kontrolle Arbeit
merken wir uns noch also welche
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten geben wir
Flüchtlingen das war der Punkt von
omiduripor Fragen vorher fragen wir ihn
noch nach der FDP dem
Bundesfinanzminister und der Chipkarte
ist das in ihren Augen vorstellbar die
Freiheit wäre da die Dinge einzukaufen
die man für den persönlichen Bedarf
braucht aber man hätte eben nicht mehr
das Bargeld in der Hand sondern eine
Chipkarte glauben Sie das ist ein guter
Gedanke werden sie den
Bundesfinanzminister dabei unterstützen
die Kommunen können selber entscheiden
und es ist gerade ja gesagt worden Herr
frei hat völlig recht es fehlt nicht nur
Geld es fehlt auch Personal und Wohnraum
und mir sagen viele Leute vor Ort wo
soll ich die Leute herkriegen die dann
extra Einkaufen Logistik betreiben und
verteilen und ganz ehrlich ja
Sachleistung die man könnte ja selau
aber auch bei den Chipkarten ich finde
der die die Bürgermeister
Oberbürgermeister sollen selber
entscheiden und das gibt grü warum es
bisher nicht so ist die sind glaube ich
jetzt auch sehr eindrücklich dargestellt
worden vom Oberbürgermeister der Stadt
Kiel würden wir und das ist der letzte
Punkt bevor wir
schauen dass es auch außerhalb
Deutschlands gamechanger geben könnte
würde etwas sich verändern in
Deutschland Herr kopmans wenn wir
Flüchtlinge schneller arbeiten ließen
das ist auch ein alter Hut das kennen
wir lange und es ist immer umstritten
die Grünen sagen ja die SPD in großen
Teilen sagt ja die Union sagt lieber
nicht weil sonst senden wir das Signal
aus dass sie bleiben können was sagen
sie ja also viele der diese Hörden sind
schon abgebaut wordens also die Hörden
war in der Vergangenheit sicher zu hoch
aber das haben wir schon längst hinter
uns gelassen also Flüchtlinge die
anerkannt werden können haben die den
vollen Zugang zum
Arbeitsmarkt ich glaube letztes Jahr war
der durchschnittliche Verfahrensdauer
7,6 Monate bei manchen Gruppen wie die
syüer Reden über dre vi Monate das heißt
die Zeit dass die kein Zugang zu den
Arbeitsmarkt haben beläuft sich wenigen
Monaten also wir reden über
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten für Menschen die
abgelehnt worden sind und da würde ich
schon sehr vorsichtig sein weil
natürlich wenn sich wiederum rumspricht
dass man in Deutschland auch wenn man
abgelehnt wird vom Tag 1 äh die volle
Möglichkeit hat auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
tätig zu werden dann kann man natürlich
wie die Familien bedienen und damit wird
diese ganze Kreislauf äh der Migration
im standand gehalten oder oder sogar an
ang V allem brauch man dann kein
Fachkräfte Einwanderungsgesetz mehr sagt
er schmunzelt und meint es ironisch na
ja so ganz einfach ist es nicht und
diese der Spurwechsel den sie kritisiert
haben das ist ja etwas was z.B Daniel
Günther als CDU Ministerpräsident sogar
ja unterstützt hat also ich glaube man
kann da anderer Meinung sein der Punkt
ist doch der warum soll ich jemand
anwerben aus irgendwelchen fernländern
wenn ich feststelle dass dass da jemand
kein Anrecht auf Asyl hat aber genau die
Fähigkeiten hat die wir brauchen ja dann
finde ich es absolut richtig zu sagen
das ist ein Dilemma aber genauso sagen
wie sie sagen bei den anerkannten das
das das sind diese ganzen
abwegungspunkte man sie können auch
sagen das sind doch pullfaktoren wenn
wir die Leute arbeiten lassen weil dann
verdienen Sie Geld aber wir erstens
brauchen wir die Fachkräfte und
natürlich haben wir dann noch viel mehr
solche märzsprüche die dann sagen wir
werden ausgenutzt wenn wir die Leute
nicht arbeiten lassen sondern die die
das können und wollen sollen ihr eigenes
Geld verdienen damit nicht auch noch zu
den anderen Integrationsproblem noch ein
finanzielles Problem dazu kommt also und
man wieder gegeneinander ausgespielt das
heißt das ist ein klassisches Dilemma
ich finde es gibt gute Gründe welchen
die abgelehnt sind eine Möglichkeit zu
öffnen wenn es für uns sinnvoll und
richtig ist wenn es nicht der Fall ist
dann müssen sie gutes argumenti man
könnte ja sagen dann kann man so
Asylbewerber nicht mehr den Vorwurf
machen dass er dem wie geht die
Formulierung Sozialstaat auf der Tasche
liegt also auf jeden Fall ist eine reine
phantomdiskussion Herr K hat ja darauf
hingewiesen heute ist es so dass auch
bei denen die im Verfahren sind nach dre
Monaten die arbeitsbeschränkungen quasi
fallen es gibt nur noch ganz wenige
Ausnahmen wenn man aus sicheren
herkunftstaten kommt oder wenn man über
seine eigene Identität täuscht aber alle
anderen dürfen nach dre Monaten arbeiten
aber dann wissen Sie was losgeht in
Deutschland sie war Bürgermeister von
Don eschingen sie wissen dass man dann
noch sich die Arbeitsgenehmigungen
besorgen muss sie deswegen geht's in der
Regel gar nicht vor diesen drei Monaten
bevor man arbeiten kann aber ich finde
es auch des eine phantomdiskussion
diejenigen Beispiels in Deutschland
leben etwa eine Million sürer ja und die
Leben in der Regel alle länger als drei
Monate hier und dort ist es so dass etwa
die Hälfte davon von sozialen
Transferleistungen abhängt also wenn wir
es schaffen würden dass diejenigen die
arbeiten können tatsächlich in
Deutschland arbeiten würden dann hätten
wir natürlich unglaublich viel erreicht
diese Diskussion geht ja jetzt so als ob
jeder der als Asylbewerber hierherkmt
sofort arbeiten könnte tatsächlich ist
es so dass diejen ja aber diejenigen die
teilweise seit 7 8 Jahren aus Syrien aus
Afghanistan hier sind da haben wir eine
ganz geringe arbeitsquote ich stell das
einfach F stimmt nicht 50%
Entschuldigung 50% ist es eine gute
arbeitsquote ehrlich gesagt 75% ist die
arbeitsquote der deutschen
Bevölkerung jüste arbeitsfähig also wenn
sie sich die Zahlen der Bundesagentur
für Arbeit anschauen ist die
Sozialhilfequote bei den Deutschen bei
5% bei den bei denen die als Ausländer
länger hier sind 21% und bei den äh
hauptherkunftsländern aus wo die
Migranten herkommen bei 47%. M wir
schmeißen uns jetzt nicht länger die
Zahlen um die Ohren wir fragen einfach
die schlaue Frau neben ihnen Frau Meer
wenn von den 216 gekommenen Flüchtlingen
50% in Arbeit sind und 50% eben nicht
das ist ungefähr die Zahl ja ist das
dann ein Erfolg oder einerfolg das ist
ein Mittel ein mittlerer Erfolg also
klar ist das Sozialforscher sagen ja
noch schlech ürigens haben wir ja nur
17% ja Sozialforscher sagen ja dass man
sozusagen der der der Staat muss die
Gemeinschaft muss erstmal investieren
sozusagen damit die Leute ihren Weg in
den normalen Arbeitsmarkt finden aber
tatsächlich glaube ich in diesem Fall
würde ich auch sagen
Vader Stadt hat wieder mal auch bisschen
also das hätte man schneller irgendwie
und konzentrierter machen können dann
hätte man diese Probleme heute nicht so
andererseits sehe ich ich glaube das
sieht jeder der in diesem Land mit
offenen Augen lebt wie viele dieser
Leute inzwischen einem begegnen überall
also in allen also meistens
Dienstleistungsberufen und
Handwerksberufen und das ist eine echte
Bereicherung also insofern können wir
eigentlich auch ganz stolz zum Teil auch
mal darauf sein
gemeinnützig gemeinnützige Arbeit Omid
nuur schlägt nicht nur Markus Söder vor
sondern auch die SPD kann sich das
vorstellen dass Asylbewerber dazu
gezwungen werden gemeinnützig zu
arbeiten können sich die Grünen das auch
vorstellen ich glaube das notwendige ist
dass wir jetzt über den arbeitsmart
sprechen dass wir die Leute in Lohn und
Brot bringen damit einfach viele
Debatten aufhören aber damit auch die
Leute den einen wichtigsten Weg gehen es
ist ehrlich gesagt bekannt
und das sagt jede Studie seit
Jahrzehnten der Integrationsmotor Nummer
1 äh in jedem Land ist der Arbeitsmarkt
und dementsprechend müssen wir den jetzt
eiglich
anwerfen okay ich habe immer noch nicht
die Antwort verstanden also sagen sie
das wäre nötig um eben ich glaube ich
glaube dass wenn man sich die Nöte auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt anschaut ja dass das
massiven Vorrang hat vor allen anderen
Diskussionen und wenn ich noch einmal
daran erinnern darf dass das
Hauptproblem in den Kommunen zu weilen
ist das Personal fehlt in Kindergärten
in Schulen und auch in der Verwaltung
einen Zwang einzu führen heißt da muss
jemand daneben stehen und das Überwachen
also wenn es in K solche Leute gibt dann
dann Kön wir drüber reden aber ich sehe
nicht wie das gehen soll würde
Arbeitserleichterung helfen würde eine
Arbeitspflicht für
gemeinnützige Tätigkeit helfen für was
denn also das kann man ja diskutieren
ich würde auch gerne verstehen warum bei
uns die ukrainischen geflüchteten zu 15%
arbeiten in anderen europäischen Ländern
zu 50 70 das mag manchmal auch mit
unserer Bürokratie zu tun haben und
nicht nur damit weil das sind ja keine
anderen Menschen das kann man können wir
den ganzen Abend diskutieren nur meine
Probleme und die Frage was machen wir in
zwei Monaten in Z Jahren wie können wir
eine humane gesteuerte
Flüchtlingspolitik organisieren dafür
hilft das auch nicht weil es glaubt doch
keiner dass wenn ich jetzt in in gana
oder in in in Niger oder in der Türkei
mich auf dem Weg mache zu sagen oh ist
jetzt die arbeitsquote 50% gibt's eine
Arbeitspflicht oder nicht das ist doch
nicht der entscheidende pullfaktor von
und die Leute sagen dann bleibe ich zu
Hause und man kann da
viele geht in andere Länder ja man ja
aber das kann man alles diskutieren n
wollen wir wirklich vor was Griechenland
wurde genannt ja ist das wirklich unser
Vorbild ich darf teilweise nicht nach
nach den Dubliner regelnenland
abschieben oder zurückschieben weil dort
menschenrechtswidrige Behandlung von von
geflüchteten S in der EU ja und das
heißt was kann do nicht jetzt sein dann
machen wie die Griechen sondern wir
müssen glaube ich einen Mittelweg finden
zu sagen klar ne wir können nicht alle
Wünsche erfüllen wir müssen pragmatisch
sein äh aber zu glauben dass das jetzt
das Problem was wir in den Kommunen
jeden Tag und jede Woche lösen müssen
dass das auch nur ansatzweise dadurch
jetzt schneller gelöst wird das und
deswegen da kriegen wir doch Steine
stadbrot von ihnen s wenn ich habe auch
Steine stadbrot ja das war Zusagen an an
an Lösung ich sag ja auch nicht dass ich
den Zauberstab habe aber wir
verschwenden ein bisschen unsere Zeit
mit Diskussion die weil sie so schwierig
ist geführt werden muss und ich hoffe
dass es wirklich wenn jetzt der
Pulverrauch der Landtagswahlen vorbei
ist ab Montag und dann sage ich mal bis
zur Europawahl da finden nämlich auch
acht Kommunalwahlen statt in den in
allen Städten und Gemeinden da haben wir
ein Zeitfenster wo wir über die
tatsächlichen Dinge und da hat ja Herr
Kopmann interessanter Gedanken und
andere darüber müssen wir reden und
nicht unsere Zeit verschwenden mit
solchen Scheinlösung aber das tun wir
doch gar nicht ich meine wir müssen doch
sprechen über Lösungen die man auch auf
nationaler Ebene umsetzen kann und die
sind wie sie sagen alle keine
gamechanger aber sie können helfen die
Dinge in die richtige Richtung zu lenken
sie könenlenken von den wirklichen nein
aber aber Sie müssen doch die Frage
beantworten warum im ersten Halbjahr
diesen Jahres in Deutschland die
Asylanträge um knapp 80% gegenüber dem
Vorjahr gestiegen sind und in Österreich
sind sie um 29% zurückgegangen das kann
man ja nur mit nationalen Maßnahmen
erklären und das kann man mit lauter
Einzelmaßnahmen erklären die man dort um
gesetzt hat um sozusagen weniger
attraktiv zu sein als andere oder
jedenfalls nicht so viel attraktiver und
deswegen das sind nicht Steine statt
Brot sondern das sind Möglichkeiten
mittel und langfristig tatsächlich zu
verträglichen Lösungen zu kommen so wir
sind an der Stelle wo wir jetzt endlich
auch in Athen Gerald Knaus begrüßen den
Architekten bekannt den bekannten
Architekten des türkeiabkommens das
geschlossen wurde 2 und gut funktioniert
hat bis insgesamt
2020 ich hoffe die Verbindung steht
einigermaßen er ist zu wichtigen
politischen Gesprächen in der
griechischen Hauptstadt und hört uns
heute Abend einen herzlichen Gruß zu
ihnen schönen guten Abend Herr Knaus wir
sprechen bisher in dieser Sendung
darüber was Deutschland tun kann was
einzelne Länder tun können was würde die
Politik in diesem Land sicherlich
erlösen wenn es insgesamt einen
Mechanismus gäbe die Zahl der Menschen
die nach Deutschland kommen allein die
schlichte Zahl der Menschen zu
begrenzen glauben Sie dass das mit
dieser gestrigen Einigung da in der EU
im Raum steht oder sagen Sie wie Rü
kopmn dass es auf gar keinen Fall eine
Lösung sein
wird ja also zunächst einmal glaube ich
dass sehr sehr viele der Dinge die bis
jetzt besprochen wurden schon aus einem
Grund nicht zu einem großen Effekt
führen werden dazu brauchen wir nur den
Blick über die Grenze nach Österreich
Herr frei hat ja erwähnt in Österreich
gibt es seit Jahren konservative
Innenminister eine konservativ geführte
Regierung und in diesem Jahr in der
ersten Jahreshälfte 2023 hat Österreich
pro Kopf mehr Asylanträge als
Deutschland also alle diese Maßnahmen
die in Deutschland diskutiert werden äh
haben nicht dazu geführt dass in in
Österreich wo es eine Rhetorik gibt die
sehr hart ist äh weniger sondern sogar
mehr Menschen einen Asylantrag stellen
und auch mehr Menschen Asyl bekommen und
der Grund ist dass Österreich und
Deutschland wie ein paar andere Länder
auch die Schweiz und Frankreich
Rechtsstaaten geblieben sind und der
große Unterschied zu anderen EU-Staaten
ist dass Menschen wissen dort werden sie
behandelt wie es in den Gesetzen
vorgesehen ist und anders wo nicht das
heißt Deutschland hat das größte
Interesse mit Österreich mit der Schweiz
mit frreich bereits an der Außengrenze
dafür zu sorgen dass grundsätzlich
weniger Menschen irregulär in die EU
kommen denn wenn sie mal in der EU sind
wird ein Land wie Deutschland wird
Österreich wird die Schweiz wird
Frankreich den Wettbewerb den Wettlauf
nach unten bei der Behandlung niemals
gewinnen und jetzt kommen wir zur
EU-Regelung was mich wirklich stört und
erstaunt ist dass wir in Deutschland da
eine total unseriöse Debatte haben jeder
der sich für einen Moment ansieht was
hier in brü seit Jahren diskutiert und
in den letzten Wochen beschlossen wurde
weiß und ich lege da meine Hand ins
Feuer obwohl ich mir vorkomme wie das
Kind das beim Andersens Kaiser sagt der
Kaiser ist nackt und hat keine Kleider
weil die meisten sagen diese asylreform
in der EU ist entweder dramatisch und
schlecht für die Menschenrechte oder es
ist der Durchbruch diese asylreform wird
nichts bewirken und ich kann sieen an
einem einzigen Beispiel sagen im letzten
Jahr sind 21000 Ägypter und 16000
bangladeschis nach Italien gekommen mit
dem Boot und wenn man jetzt sagt wir
verpflichten Italien dazu etwas zu tun
was Sie immer schon tun konnten nämlich
hallo hören sie mich sehr gut wir hören
sie gut ist die Verbindung noch da
Verbindung ist gut wenn man jetzt
Italien dazu zwingen würde das zu tun
was Sie immer schon tun konnten nämlich
verpflichtende grenzverfahren in 12
Wochen dann machen die für diese 21000
Ägypter und 16000 bangladeschis in 12
Wochen grenzverfahren aber wie Herr
Kopmann ja schon erwähnt hat es gibt
neun Rückführungen im Jahr nach
Bangladesch im Durchschnitt und 300 nach
Ägypten diese 40.000 Menschen würden
also irgendwo in Italien ein schnelles
Asylverfahren haben
ja jetzt kriegen Sie Ihr Handy gereicht
was jetzt los ist hören sie mich wir
hören sie immer noch gut und wir haben
sie nicht wir haben sie nicht angeruf
hören sie mich ja wir hören sie immer
noch sehr gut und haben sie nicht
angerufen und sind a so Entschuldigung
sind noch mal zurück in wir hab ein
Telefon geläutet im Studio in Athen ja
ja sind noch mal zurück mit mit dem
Gedanken diese EU asyreform organisiert
offensichtlich in anführungstrichen dass
die Menschen zunächst außen an der
EU-Grenze bleiben sollen ohne dass man
aber gelöst hat wohin sie dann
eigentlich können wenn sie erst einmal
in diesen Aufnahmelagern außerhalb der
europäischen Grenzen
behalten werden Herr kuupmannz insofern
sagen sie auch wir müssen und der ist ja
gerade offensichtlich gescheitert einen
Deal eigentlich mit Tunesien haben wir
sollten auch eigentlich einen Deal mit
Ägypten haben wir sollten den Deal mit
der Türkei erneuern Fragezeichen und
zwar dringend und schnell mit Marokko
brauchen wir auch ein Abkommen Mar mit
allen wichtigen transit äh Ländern mm
aber was wir auch brauchen ist dass wir
uns die Möglichkeit eröffnen auch
migrationsabkommen zu schließen mit
sonstigen Drittstaaten die weder
Herkunftsländer noch Transitländer sind
äh weil wir dann z.B die Probleme die
jetzt schon auf uns zukommen und die wo
man vor darauf vorbereitet sein dass das
noch viel schlimmer werden kann nämlich
an unsereer Ostgrenze zu Belarus und
Russland da steht die Drohung ständig im
Raum äh dass Russland und Belarus wieder
das tun was sie 2021 kurz vor dem
ukrainekrieg gemacht haben nämlich
Migration als Mittel benutzen um die
Europäische Union zu destabilisieren äh
um äh die Unterstützung für die Ukrainer
zu untergraben wir stehen momentan mit
Lehen wir können nur mit mit
letztendlich illegalen nicht rechtlichen
Mitteln diese Menschen zurückweisen
daran hindern ein Asylantrag zu stellen
wir brauchen die Möglichkeit um diese
Menschen in einen Drittstaat zu bringen
wo sie dann ein Asylverfahren
durchlaufen können und wo sie auch
Schütz bekommen werden weil dann nehmen
wir die erpressungsmöglichkeit weg weil
niemand wird mirr nach Belarus kommen W
wenn die Menschen wissen dass sie z.B in
Albanien ein asülverfahren durch
durchgeführt bekommen und dort Schutz
bekommen wollen sie wollen ja nach
Deutschland da in die Niederlande in die
Schweiz nicht nach Albanien das ist ein
komplizierter Mechanismus aber wir haben
schlaue Zuschauer die haben auch die
Debatte der let letzten Wochen
verstanden Herr Knaus zu ihnen genau
diese Frage in welchen Fristen sind denn
Abkommen neue Abkommen möglich wie eben
damals das türkeiabkommen und wird
Erdogan so etwas mit Europa überhaupt
noch mal
abschließen ja also Griechenland ist ein
gutes Beispiel ich bin hier jetzt in
Athen ich spreche mit Ministern der
griechischen Regierung die Regierung
mitzotakis hat sich ja in den letzten
Wochen Deutschland gewannt sogar über
die Medien der migrationsminister hat an
Olaf Scholz appelliert Deutschland und
Griechenland und andere die ein
Interesse daran haben und betroffen sind
sollten jetzt ein neues Angebot an die
Türkei zusammenstellen Griechenland ist
bereit bis zu 20.000 Syrer jedes Jahr
legal aufzunehmen und bittet Deutschland
hier jetzt ernsthaft zu verhandeln und
was ich bis jetzt höre hier aus
Griechenland es gab zwar schon Gespräche
aber das was ich 2016 gesehen habe unter
der niederländischen Präsidentschaft
dass sofort Leute nach Athen Ken jetzt
sofort sich zusammensetzen über das
lange Wochenende auf der höchsten Ebene
der Regierung und auch der Parteichefs
der Ampelkoalition darüber nachdenken
was können wir anbieten ist Deutschland
bereit der Türkei etwas wirklich
attraktives anzubieten um den für
Deutschland bei weiten wichtigsten
migrations Deal denn Deutschland ist
davon mit Griechenland am meisten
betroffen abzuschließen die Frage geben
wir gleich da gibt viele komplizierte
Fragen da gibt die geben wir gleich mit
aber daran wird nicht gearbeitet ihrem
Einverständnis nach Frankfurt weiter
omit noripur warum spürt man da nicht
sofort ein Interesse diese Verträge zu
erneuern umzusetzen und sie zu schließen
zunächst einmal ist richtig dass wir
migrationsabkommen brauchen das sagen
wir auch die ganze Zeit Herr krupman hat
ja darauf hingewiesen es gab
beispielsweise Gespräche mit Tunesien
tunesien hat dieser Tage gesagt dass sie
das eine ich nicht wollen mm ich glaube
dass der Zentrale Grund auch einer der
wichtigsten ist warum es in Türke R ja
gerade von der Türkei also Tunesien ja
sch da will ich ja gerade hin es ist
immer derselbe Mechanismus und wenn ich
jetzt mal darauf rekurieren darf ich
höre Gerald Knaus das seit Jahren sagen
und ich finde seit Jahren recht dieser
Abschlüsse wird es am Ende des Tages
effektiv nur geben wenn die europäischen
Staaten auch bereit den Leute
aufzunehmen dieser Türkei Deal hatte ein
zentrales Element das war nämlich dass
eins zu ein so viel Leute in die Türkei
geschoben werden auch aus der Türkei
dann aufgenommen werden in die EU das
haben die europäischen Staaten nicht
gemacht und das gibt viele Gründe warum
man
viel Kritik üben darf auch an Ankara
aber dass dieser Grund von der dass
dieses dieser Teil des Deals von den
Europäern nicht eingehalten worden ist
ist einfach Fakt wenn wir jetzt über
migrationsabkommen reden müssen wir
solche Dinge mitdenken dann sonst werden
wir nicht zum Abschluss kommen die
Zeiten wo man gedacht hat wir gehen
jetzt mal mit dem Geldkoffer
irgendwoohin und wedeln damit und dann
unterschreiben alle die gibt es nicht ja
aber vor allen Dingen muss man eben mit
den richtigen Ländern sprechen also man
hat 10 Jahre verhandelt um ein
migrationsabkommen mit Indien zu haben
aus Indien kommen vielleicht 1000
Asylbewerber pro Jahr das ist völlig
irrelevant und jetzt spricht man mit
Kolumbien und mit Usbekistan aber wer
war denn vor 10 Jahren Innenminister
eigentlich und jetzt redet man über
Kolumbien und Usbekistan und da kommen
auch keine Migranten her also es wä in
der Tat Kirgisistan genauso da gilt es
aber genauso und K gilt es genauso das
sind alles keine hauptmigrationsländer
nach Deutschland mit der Türkei müsste
man sprechen und da müsste auch nicht
ein Sonderbeauftragter der Regierung
sprechen sondern da müsste der
Bundeskanzler sich drum kümmern damals
beim letzten eutürkei Deal da war die
Bundeskanzlerin in der Türkei und
deswegen muss man an der Stelle wirklich
die Frage stellen wo ist eigentlich der
Bundeskanzler der müsste sich gemeinsam
mit Emmanuel macron mit ursola
vonderlein an die Spitze der Debatte
stellen auch was Tunesien anbelangt
Marokko Algerien wir werden sonst keine
Lösung bekommen und vor allen Dingen
glaube ich der Hauptschlüssel sind nicht
die Herkunftsländer der Hauptschlüssel
sind die Drittstaaten und da findet
überhaupt nichts statt ich glaube da
haben sie vollkommen Recht auch eine
Frage des Respekts einfach gegenüber den
verhandlungspartnert man nich hin die
eine Frage nach Tunesien noch Herr Knaus
ganz kurz wenn ich darum bitten darf
dieser Deal ist ja von Ursula vonderlein
angestrengt worden mit dem Satz
verbunden worden nicht mehr die
Schlepper legen fest wer nach Europa
kommt sondern die EU das war in die
Zukunft formuliert
und wird jetzt erstmal nicht wahr werden
muss man da trotzdem dran bleiben auch
wenn einem der Diktator mit dem man da
verhandelt nicht
gefällt also Tunesien zeigt uns sehr gut
dass es nicht damit getan ist über
migrationsabkommen zu reden oder
irgendwelche Abkommen zu schließen Wien
sondern dass es sehr sehr stark auf den
Inhalt ankommt ich meine ich kann zum
Zahnarzt gehen und er repariert meine
Zähne oder ich gehe zum Zahnarzt und er
zieht alle meine Zähne und im zweiten
Fall ist der Zahnarzt nicht hilfreich
das Abkommen mit Tunesien führt dazu
dass mehr Menschen kommen seit einigen
Monaten weil sich die Menschenrechtslage
in Tunesien verschlechtert hat und
gleichzeitig war überhaupt nicht klar
was Tunesien angeboten wurde also man
hat nicht erklärt wie man hofft dass
Tunesien irreguläre Migration reduziert
der Präsident ist auf die Idee gekommen
die Menschen in die Wüste zu
verschleppen und man hat auch nicht klar
gesagt was Tunesien davon hat man hat
also einfach gesagt wir schießen von der
Hüfte irgendwie ein Abkommen und das
Ergebnis war ein Disaster aber auch zur
Erinnerung mit der Türkei wurde sechs
Monate lang sinnlos verhandelt man hat
den Türken Geld angeboten von dem die
Türken wussten es gibt es gar nicht in
der EU man hat gesagt stoppt irgendwie
die Leute ohne einen Mechanismus ähm ich
glaube das Entscheidende ist wieder die
seriöität und dass Ursula von derlin in
dem Fall sogar ohne Rücksprache mit den
anderen Kommissaren
in Brüssel einfach losgefahren ist um
mit Meloni die sich irgendwie gedacht
hat wir machen sowas wie mit Libyen also
wir bitten die Tunesier macht doch ein
paar Menschenrechtsverletzungen dann
kommt keiner mehr das ist kein guter
Ansatz um Ergebnisse zu erzielen aber
auch mit Tunesien und vor allem mit
anderen Ländern mit Senegal mit Marokko
könnte man wenn man sich kurz ein echtes
Konzept überlegt natürlich zu
Abschlüssen kommen vor allem wenn man
den Menschen legale Mob ermöglicht warum
ist es nicht Beispiel Türkei ein Angebot
auf dem Tisch dass diejenigen Türken die
ein Visum bekommen ab jetzt ein
einjähriges Visum bekommen da muss man
nicht ständig prüfen und im Gegenzug
soll die Türkei wieder bereit sein ab
einem Stichtag Leute zurückzunehmen von
den griechischen Inseln um irreguläre
Migration zu reduzieren und gleichzeitig
stellen wir sicher dass in der Türkei
der UNHCR für die die wir zurückbringen
die Asylverfahren macht und dann können
wir es machen im Einklang mit der
Europäischen Menschenrechtskonvention
also an diesen Dingen muss man arbeiten
und mein ich hoffe dass nach den
Landtagswahlen die Spitzen der Ampel
Koalition mit den Spitzen der Union sich
vielleicht zusammentreffen und überlegen
wie man hier diese Durchbrüche mit den
wichtigsten Ländern Interesse
Deutschlands gemeinsam erreichen kann
Herr Kämpfer ich glaube da kommen wir
jetzt genau an den Punkt wenn wir sagen
wir brauchen einen gamechanger dann ist
er in diesem Bereich zu suchen das heißt
erstens wir brauchen europäische Lösung
ich verstehe ganz viel
an den Detailregelung aber am Ende kann
auch so eine Politik nur europäisch
vermittelt werden und und und der
nächste Punkt ist wirklich wir brauchen
diese Abkommen wir brauchen Sie
natürlich die müssen im Interesse der
Länder sein da geht's um Geld da geht's
um visaerleichterung die Staaten müss
ein Interesse daran haben mit uns das zu
machen weil wir hab wollen ja auch was
und natürlich muss muss Teil dieser
Abkommen sein dass sie eben keine
Menschenrechtsverletzung oder zumindest
mal deutlich weniger als heute machen
damit nicht mehr so viele Menschen sich
auf diese lebensgefährliche Reise auf ü
Mittel mehr machen und immer mehr
Menschen dort sterben und dann können
wir dann und dann und der gamechanger
heißt für mich jedenfalls nicht dann
gibt es keine Migration mehr sondern das
verschafft uns überhaupt erst den Atem
und auch den politischen Spielraum zu
sagen dann haben wir
landesaufnahmeprogramme wir wir in sch
hol hatten wir das mit Frauen und
Kindern aus Äthiopien dann kommen eben
nicht nur die die am meisten für die
Schlepper bezahlen können oder die die
Robustheit haben sondern auch andere die
mindestens genau das gleiche Recht haben
Hilfe zu finden aber dafür brauchen wir
weniger Druck über irregulare Migration
damit wir überhaupt eine politische
Diskussion und für die Kommune
Planbarkeit hinbekommen dass wir sagen
okay ich weiß immerem halben Jahr da
werden die nächsten 200 Frauen mit
Kindern so war es in stwigholstein
kommen dann kann ich mich draf
vorbereiten so kann funktionieren und
das ist was anderes als einfach zu sagen
es dürfen keine Flüchtlinge mE
kommenritt nach dem ersten und wir haben
verstanden Herr kopm dass es diese
europäische Reform diese
asylrechtsverschärfung die es die ist
nur geben wird und nur sinnvoll geben
wird wenn es auf der anderen Seite
Abkommen der gerade besprochenen Art
gibt na ja es wird sich vielleicht auch
ohne diese Abkommen geben aber dann wird
sie nicht gelingen wir sie die Situation
no verschlechter W sie würde sich noch
mehr verschlechtern und wir hören Herr
noripur von ihnen noch mal eine Antwort
auf die Frage wo ist der
Bundeskanzler der Bundeskanzler
koordiniert das mit undter ist natürlich
ein zentraler Bestandteil all dieser
Bemühungen die wir miteinander abstimmen
ich sehe nicht besonders Spiel disens in
in dies all diesen Fragen ich kann aber
nur wiederholen was alle gesagt haben es
gibt nicht den einen Zaubertrick mit dem
man die Lösung tatsächlich herbeizaubert
es wird dauern und deshalb ist es
notwendig bei den schnellen Fragen jetzt
alles drauf zusetzen dass es den
Kommunen machbar gemacht wird und dass
sie entlastet werden weil dort wir
gerade am meisten setzen hier einen
Punkt ich darf mich bei allen Gästen
ganz herzlich bedanken danke auch nach
Frankfurt und nach Athen an diesem Abend
danke Ihnen hier im Studio